taylor is with us taylor is in fresno
california
hi taylor how are you i'm good how are
you dave
better than i deserve what's up
um so i barely started watching your uh
videos a couple
weeks ago and right now i'm i'm on baby
step two
so i only have student loans um
including some personal loans that i
took out with some family members
to get me through school i don't have
any credit cards
and my car is paid off so right now i'm
trying to decide
how to go about paying back my student
loans especially because um at zero
percent interest i haven't made any
payments before
did you graduate and i i graduated in
december
oh last year okay cool yeah so right
after i got out then covet happened and
i wasn't making any payments i didn't i
wasn't required to
so this would be the start of it but i'm
having a hard time
thinking of how to do that because i'm
going to be experiencing
kind of some big life changes soon um
currently i'm living with my family rent
free
i'm not making a lot of money because of
the pandemic
i'm at target and i'm making 20 000 a
year
and i live in an area where what's your
degree in i'm sorry what's your degree
in my degree is in marketing
but i live in fresno california so
what's that mean
i don't do marketing in fresno a lot of
opportunities to grow here
and so i i would kind of need to move
there's no opportunity for marketing in
fresno california
i mean i would say more specifically for
what i want to do i want to do cosmetic
marketing and like luxury retail
marketing and that just doesn't exist
here
so are you open to moving to places
where that does exist
yeah so that's kind of uh what i'm
getting to next is
i'm actually uh waiting for my boyfriend
to immigrate here he's going
he's coming from russia and he's going
to be immigrating here in just a few
months
and we both want to move down to los
angeles together
he wants to work at lax and i want to do
some marketing down there
and um there's just so many moving parts
that it really scares me to start
draining my savings
i should and start paying for my uh
student loans
it should that should scare you yeah
yeah this is uh this is unwise and
that's why it would scare you
um because you you just painted up this
uh fantasy situation that exists in l.a
in your mind and doesn't exist
if you can't find a way to do high-end
cosmetic marketing in a city the size of
fresno
you are going to get slayed in l.a
this is not about the city this is about
you
and your mom and dad are dead set
against your whole plan aren't they
um i wouldn't say that i would say
they've been pretty supportive but they
are
scared of the prices of rent for sure
well it sounds to me like your
perspective on this la thing
you've not applied you've not found any
jobs am i wrong on that
um i actually did have a job lined up
after college but it fell through
yeah but i'm not talking about the past
i'm talking about as we speak today and
you go
we want to move to la me and the
boyfriend and all this business
do you have something lined up do you
have some prospects at least some
targets
um i will say i haven't been as active
as they should be in applying because
it's so uncertain of when my boyfriend
is coming
and i just don't feel comfortable moving
down there by myself and handling rent
by myself
if you were my daughter here's what i
would tell you
you need to stay separated from him
until you establish yourself
as a confident young woman in a career
field
i think you're chasing a fantasy here
this sounds very romantic and very
different and i think you're
about to step in it the bear trap is
going to snap on your leg kiddo
you need to establish your own
independence as a sharp young lady
and then you'll be in a position to make
better decisions about relationships
i'm a 60 year old dad who has raised
grown kids and has six grandkids
i support ministries on sex trafficking
and slavery to end it
all over the world i just spoke to two
young men here just in the lobby just a
few minutes ago that was meeting with
our family foundation
that are from england working on the
same issues
um it turns out
not everyone is who they say they are
shocking when you are
sweet and young and naive
moms and dads uh not everybody is who
they say they are
now not everyone immigrating from russia
is a bad person and i'm not certainly
not saying that i'm
i have you know would have great
admiration from someone wanting to leave
communism and come to the greatest
country in the world
uh but not everyone coming from russia
attaching themselves as a boyfriend meet
me in la
will shack up together is who they say
they are
this i know um and so i don't know that
that particular young lady is getting
ready to be the victim of a catfish
but a scam but it's very
it's as possible as possible
in addition to that and let me tell you
what lends credence to that
okay i'm just the old guy that loves my
daughters
okay and is wise and um
the way you get wise is you observe evil
and you observe stupid and you are a
victim to it a few times
and it teaches you wisdom the hard way
and so
uh the fact that she has no
freaking plan about where she's gonna
live how she's gonna eat her what her
job is
and and has not applied herself to her
career field at home
in fresno tells me that same part of her
brain that's not doing that
is maybe susceptible to being harmed
in a scam relationship situation now
that all went through my head and i
didn't say it out loud
but it's fair to our listenership to say
that out loud that that's why i'm saying
that that's why i said your parents are
against it because i was hoping and
praying
that her parents were speaking up but
they feel like they're not allowed to
say anything
yeah they were somewhat supportive and
and so here's what's going on
there there's there's calculated risk
where we look at it and we say okay
i'm going to go white water rafting and
i know that
if i pay attention to the guide and i
watch the video and i get in i don't do
something stupid in the boat
there's a chance that i'm going to get
thrown out of the boat i might bruise
something i might break something but
that's a calculated risk and you just
jumped out of an airplane the other day
skydiving yeah
and you were training yeah you had uh
you had you're attached to somebody who
knows what they're doing there was
really automatic uh computer deployment
on the shoot
yeah if we got below a certain yeah
altitude at a certain speed
these guys have done this thousands and
thousands of times um
i didn't just go jump out of an airplane
right and that's what la looks like here
i'm gonna wait until the russian
boyfriend shows up
then we're gonna move together then i'm
gonna try to find something in los
angeles which spits people out
in about 30 minutes if you if you have a
decent plan
if it's not shut down by governor well
there's that too and and you've got an
economy that has been
severely uh artificially uh suppressed
there it so she just didn't have a plan
and it's not you don't have to take the
jump off the cliff chasing the dream is
not as romantic as they make it out in
the movies it's not
wee and we just hope it works out no i
mean it is
it is a plotting practical plan and you
take
steps and you got to earn it along the
way you don't just show up in la and get
the high
glitz high glamour marketing job so
there just wasn't
any kind of a plan behind that which
scares me about the
uh every element of the plan everything
about that is
for her i'm not affected i'm not going
to la
so it doesn't affect me i'm not going to
meet a russian person that i've never
met in a relationship
with and that so doesn't affect me but
you know she called us to ask us what to
do and
i i have to try to love someone that's
calling here well and tell them the
truth
um but i i i fear i didn't um
if i had said all of that i don't think
it would have done any good because i
think she's going to do whatever she's
going to give great advice i think
her establishing her own career as an
independent woman
and then we work the relationship out
but there's i'm just not a fan
of somebody that if he's not willing to
put a ring on it
you shouldn't be willing to move to a
city with him shack up and try to
support him while he gets going you
establish yourself first
if he loves you and he's committed and
he's in for the long haul and i say this
is a guy that's been married almost 23
years
then he'll wait and he'll be fine and i
would tell my daughter josie that
well you know oh by the way establish
himself and prove himself to be an
actual reality and not mythology
that's true yeah there's a little test
market here we're doing you know
just to establish we call it in the
business proof texting we put something
in the market to prove out the theory to
prove out the hypothesis
before we launch the whole freaking
thing and then
we find if it falls fa on its face or
not and that's what we're doing here so
um yeah the um
yeah just just um moms and dads i if you
got a 25 year old living in your house
uh meg meeker dr meg meeker the speaking
of the smart conference with ken and i
this weekend
would tell you it is your job to
interfere in their life
now if they're on their own and they've
established themselves
then you know good boundaries are in
order and they're paying their own bills
and you're not giving them any money
but if you're providing them shelter or
money then
it is your obligation to continue to
speak into their lives
and if they don't like that then they
can go provide their own shelter and
their own money by the way one of the
ways that parents can do that dave with
adult children because the dynamic has
changed is ask them some very
straightforward clear
questions and and leave it to them
because if you make a statement
a 25 year old kid even a 14 year old kid
is going to push back a little bit but
if you ask a question
it puts the ball on them and then they
have skin in the game
when you say hey things like um do you
have any jobs lined up do you have any
targets of companies that you would like
to apply for i should have
been a target right yeah that's right
have are they hiring
and let them sit with their own answers
let them
sit with the fact that they don't have
an answer at that point once they begin
and you get them to the place where they
realize oh i don't have a plan
this doesn't even make sense in my own
head then you got a chance to step in
and go hey
how can i help how can i step in and
help you make some some decisions on
this what are some things that you can
do
but if you ask some piercing questions
and leave them be okay not talking mom
and dad
let them wrestle with it um you might
find that that's a really great way to
jump into that but you got to be
okay at some point going i think this is
a bad idea but let me tell you why i
think it's a bad idea
if there's something i think it can harm
you if there's some red flags i think it
could harm you to not call out red flags
it's not an act of love
it's an act of cowardice i agree and so
you've got to call the red flags you got
to say this is what it is
um we had a team member many many years
around here misbehave
and uh ended up having to leave due to
the misbehavior
and as we revisited it with some of the
leaders they always said well
you know every time i had interaction
with this person it always kind of felt
weird
but nobody ever talked about it to each
other but if five of us had gotten
together and said you know it feels
weird
and so we developed a new saying after
that if it feels weird
generally it's because it's weird
there's a reason it feels that way
you know and so investigate poke into it
if there's a red flag
you know there should you you know and
common dadgum
sense should give some of you red flags
on some things
and it's your job then if you love
someone to poke into it now again
if they're a freestanding household
they're 32 years old they've got two
kids and they're a married couple
you don't have the right to just walk in
there with your money boots
that's a boundary violation but even
then
you would treat them as a friend and
what would you do with your friend what
ken said
what i would do with my friend is i
started asking a bunch of questions that
made them uncomfortable
that's what i do with one of my personal
friends yeah if that happened
versus walking in and saying you're
stupid as a parent i don't ever want to
get to a situation where my kid looks at
me and says why didn't you tell me dad
yeah
why didn't you tell me yeah i'd rather
be mad at me on the front end
i learned a new phrase today i didn't
know it's called catfish
he's still learning folks i'm still
learning 60 years it's still growing
this is the dave ramsey show